je crois tout d'abord profondément qu'il
est dans l'intérêt de notre pays de
notre république de parvenir enfin un
dialogue construit responsable entre
collectivités territoriales et état pas
seulement au niveau national mais aussi
sur le terrain dans les relations au
quotidien entre services déconcentrés et
collectivités puisque les enjeux
budgétaires et la construction d'un
pacte financier dans la durée occuperont
une place importante dans nos échanges
je le pense ce matin mais au-delà de ce
matin dans les semaines et les mois qui
viennent je veux en préambule souligné
l'effort de maîtrise budgétaire réalisé
par les collectivités ces cinq dernières
années
on ne part pas d'une page blanche
elles ont réduit leurs dépenses de
fonctionnement alors que l'état
continuait alors transférer des charges
de manière assumée ou cachés notamment
travers des normes ou des décisions
prises unilatéralement qui s'imposait à
elles mais elles ont aussi réduit par la
force des choses
leurs dépenses d'investissement alors
que nous connaissons tous l'importance
de l'investissement public local je veux
aussi rappeler que les perspectives de
maîtrise budgétaire ne serait faire fi
du principe d'autonomie financière des
collectivités territoriales corollaire
du principe de libre administration
c'est dans ce cadre que doit être
abordée la question de l'évolution des
effectifs de la fonction publique
territoriale et de leur gestion
le sénat sera très vigilant au respect
de ces principes
mais pour construire une relation de
confiance au-delà des aspects
budgétaires
il faut que l'état monsieur le premier
ministre s'engage véritablement
respecter les élus leur rôle l'action
des collectivités
ça ne sera pas difficile pour vous vous
en êtes issue
les élus locaux ne sont pas des pions
qu'on bougerait au gré des humeurs du
jour ce sont au fait des pièces
maîtresses du développement territorial
de notre pays et les vigies de notre
république et j'ai lu je le crois
sincèrement ne veulent plus de big bang
territorial qu'à canal bien sûr il y a
des clarifications des ajustements de
compétences rapportés ici ou là mais
attention les élus veulent de la
stabilité de la prévisibilité dans leur
cadre d'action comme dans leurs
ressources
c'est la seule manière me semble utile
de pouvoir conduire des politiques
publiques raisonner aujourd'hui nous
devons laisser respirer les territoires
pour reprendre le titre d'un récent
rapport du sénat nous devons les laisser
innover expérimenté en leur faisant
confiance en ordonnant un droit à la
différenciation territoriales pour
adapter un certain nombre de normes aux
réalités des territoires
je pense en particulier à nos outre-mer
nous nous pourrons atteindre cet
objectif qu'en menant une action résolue
pour lutter contre l'inflation normative
qui pèsent sur nos collectivités et
empêchent d'agir
c'est un axe prioritaire d'action pour
le sénat mais il faudra aussi avoir le
courage de revoir les lois sru et allure
qui traduisent au fond une défiance
vis-à-vis des élus et des libertés
locales et dont les résultats en termes
de logements construits et de diversité
de logements sont très loin des
espérances
c'est donc un changement de culture que
nous devons aboutir pour ces c est de
tout décider en centrale
la france n'est pas uniforme non la
france n'est pas uniforme et tous les
territoires qui la composent qu'ils
soient urbains ruraux ultramarins mérite
la même attention
il n'en est pas de plus
in que d'autres nous devons donc
rassemblé des territoires ne pas opposer
entre eux les différents niveaux de
collectivités pour fédérer les énergies
le sénat y verra nous devons aussi
repenser une doctrine global
d'aménagement du territoire qui est une
politique nécessaire et modernes pour
lutter contre la fracture territoriale
et mettre en place les outils adaptés
pour la mener à bien
le sénat a récemment formulé plusieurs
propositions à cet égard je sais que les
associations en formuleront également
monsieur le premier ministre je veux
vous dire que vous pourrez compter sur
le sénat pour accompagner à sa place le
processus de dialogue que vous initiez
avec les associations de l'ue dont le
rôle constitutionnel qui est celui du
sénat et avec son approche que mes
collègues vont vous préciser au cours de
la matinée
nous soutiendrons les démarches qui
renforce les libertés locales car c'est
ainsi que nous pourrons réformer notre
pays dans le cadre d'un partenariat
respectueux qui ne saurait s'affranchir
des principes de libre administration et
d'autonomie financière souhaite donc nos
travaux de la matinée se place dans
cette perspective est soit fructueux
je vous remercie